i wish i had naruto shadow konjutsu
because it's definitely gonna take more
than one of me to get this stuff done i
mean come on
hello whoa
hello everyone it is me elise and today
i am making every single dish from
naruto naruto's a very popular anime so
if you don't know what it is
i don't know what to tell you naruto's
favorite food is what
ramen yes that's obviously what most
people think about but there are so many
other foods that appear
so i am going to take it upon myself to
show you every single thing
from this anime it's going to be a great
time so in naruto in the anime and in
the filler episodes you can see them
eating something called mitarashi dango
and hanamidango for this one today i'm
gonna make the mitarashi one so
let's do it okay so in my bowl here i
have the mochiko
sweet rice flour gradually add water we
kind of want to get like a cookie dough
texture
so i got the texture now i have to roll
it into
one inch balls then they're gonna boil
in some water when they're done cool in
a nice bath and for the glaze you'll
need
sugar soy sauce mirin and cornstarch
stir until thickened
the mochi is done usually there's about
three to four mochi
on one skewer this is kind of long i'm
going to put three on this
ah all i have to do is
pour the sauce on it oh yeah me and my
mitarashi dango
i'm gonna try it it's dripping all over
my hand
i enjoy this a lot i'm gonna eat this
i'll just have to make another one
all right there's lots of other stuff
that i gotta make let's go
i'm going to be making the fried rice
that itachi made
for sasuke when he made a big meal when
they were a kid and i'm excited to make
this one because
i get to use my wok i'm going to start
with some butter
i got two eggs egg crack one-handed
gonna stir-fry that up onions in
all right this has been saucing for a
little bit i got some pre-cooked rice i
gotta throw that in there
i forgot the garlic i can still throw it
in right i got some soy sauce
sesame oil a little bit of mirin get a
little sweetness in the fried rice
yeah just a little bit of mirin sesame
oil
i forgot to cut the green onions so
that's what i'm doing now
oh yeah that's what they call
fried rice i should taste this
it's good okay so the fried rice is
complete
and i am just pouring it into this bowl
because the way hitachi has it set up is
in like a big
large mound pat that in there all right
we're gonna pour it out let's see what
happens
there we go and voila
our fried rice is here and ready to
enjoy
not yet i got a lot of other stuff to
make let's go briefly interrupting to
catch you guys up on the ramen i know
that's why you clicked on this video
that's what you want to see and yes
i am making traditional ramen and yes it
does take 12 hours
we're going to go back to the past we're
going to talk to past elise and she's
going to show us how she made the ramen
broth and then we're going to keep it
going past the lease
it's me past elites you know i'm up at
six a.m in the morning to make some
broth
let's get started okay so since i'm
making a traditional tonkatsu broth
i have to use pork i got some pig's feet
and i also got some pig neck bones rinse
the pork real quick and then add fresh
water to boil we're going to take this
to the stove
let this boil for like 10 minutes or so
the like gross stuff from the pig's feet
and the neck bones are gonna like come
to the top we're gonna skim it off
and then we will be ready to make the
broth so while the meat is boiling
get out i got the onions
scallions green onions some knobs of
ginger
garlic a leek and a
what is this bok choy bok choy
these go in the soup and help give it
flower
i'm now putting in nice and fresh water
for the broth let me start screaming i
can also add in all my vegetables
the broth is clear the bones are in all
the vegetables are there
this is now going to cook for 12 hours
now back to present elise our ramen
is going strong come look at it mr ramen
is doing what it's gotta do all right so
now i'm gonna make the onigiri
this should be relatively ac so i wet my
hand
now i'm just gonna mold the rice
together
you gotta make like a triangle type
shape the shaping it isn't too difficult
at the car wash
all right that's our bottom half
traditionally it's stuffed with
a pickled plum the umaboshi so i'm gonna
put that right in the center
the one that hinata makes doesn't look
like it's a stuffed one it looks like
she put all the like fillings and stuff
on the top but either way that's what
we're doing
and i'm gonna cover it with this rice
here forcefully mold everything together
ah we're gonna decorate it to look
like naruto i used carrots for his ears
and seaweed for his eyes whiskers and
headband
we kind of got a smile going on damn it
i broke it
on his headband she used a piece of
naruto namesake this is a fish cake
which is also called naruto maki
and she used this to be like the leaf
village head symbol
damn it i just realized his hair i can
use the radish
okay okay we're getting somewhere
honestly i will say hers is a lot better
than mine
it is it doesn't look anything like him
it's the thought that counts
so now i'm going to make the bento box
from
the bell scene that's what i'm making
okay let's do it
so the bento box is really easy i have
this little square box here so we got
some rice here
pack that to the side i wish my bento
box had a divider
like theirs does this is just a
rectangle
and in the center of the rice they have
pickled plums
i'm gonna put one of those right in the
center
they got some vegetables over there on
the side so i sauteed some
oranges this is not an orange i sauteed
some carrots and onions together
and that'll be our little vegetable
mixture on the side i also have some
pickled radish here
i'm gonna put some of that in there as
well why
just because and last but of course not
least
we have a boiled egg nice and beautiful
and boiled we're gonna split this in
half
right there beautiful
the bento box is now complete
i guess i can try i've never had a
pickled
radish before
i have had a pickled radish before me
and my boiled egg
say cheers
i'm gonna set this down next to the
onigiri because at the end i want
everything
to be beautiful what do i got next on
the list oh
i gotta cook a chicken or was it a duck
it was a duck but i bought a chicken
so i took that thing and i seasoned it
up gave it a little rub
then i put it in the oven at 350 degrees
for like 40 minutes and it came out all
nice and golden and tasted delicious
okay i'm gonna do a little traditional
yakiniku
okay naruto shikamaru choji you know
they always be at the barbecue
i'm trying to partake in that i realize
i probably can't light a fire
inside the house like a lit lit fire for
real so i just ended up using a grill
pan
got my seasoned meat put a little onions
up on there and then i grilled it just
like they did at the barbecue
y'all i really be whipping it up in the
kitchen and it tasted divine
all right it is finally time everything
with the ramen has been complete i
strained the broth after about 11 and a
half
hours and i also made a tare which is
used to season the broth and give it
that nice deep umami flavor
i have all my things to assemble
my ichiraku ramen the noodles the eggs
the naruto
the bamboo shoot the green onions the
pork belly the seaweed the tare
the broth everything is here
let's assemble baby girl
okay so first you start with the tare
which has
been seasoned so nicely to give it that
nice umami salty flavor
oh yeah let's get a little bit of the
broth oh this broth that we spent 12
hours with let's place some noodles
in there oh now we can do the rest of
the stuff
just placing everything nicely to make
my beautiful ichiraku ramen oh my god
naruto would be so
proud oh my god
the moment we've all been waiting for i
just want to take a bite now it's been a
long
12 hours it was worth it
yes absolutely wow
i cooked every single dish from naruto
unfortunately i am a liar i definitely
forgot a few key recipes like some of
the dishes from hitachi's feast i didn't
show you guys how i made the curry of
life
how could i forget the meal that sasuke
and naruto were eating during the first
major arc of the series
i in fact did not make every single dish
from naruto but i try
as you guys can see there's a lot of
traditional japanese food that did
appear in naruto other than
his trademark ramen oh you know one
thing i did forget
jiraiya's popsicle this was a hard
challenge but it was a lot of fun
my little naruto itadakimasu
and thank you guys for watching
[Music]
you